for a few seconds at a time throughout
testimony the inquiry listened to the
horns that people in downtown Ottawa
listened to for days sometimes non-stop
it was just day-to-day living within my
own home living in fear no Taxi
no Uber
no para transfer
no grocery delivery which I depended on
Victoria de Laurent has a visual
impairment she says the Convoy
diminished her independence and left her
with long-term hearing loss vertigo and
other problems long after the trucks
finally left I was able before to listen
to Media for example at a normal level
of say four now I have to turn it to six
I just didn't feel that there was any
support available for us
Ottawa city councilors and Business
Leaders repeatedly spoke about
businesses Frozen and residents asking
for help facing a lack of response a
lack of support and a lack of
information from police and the city the
Ottawa Police Service was heavily
criticized throughout the Convoy at the
inquiry their lawyer pushed back a
ticket though that you would agree with
me that there may be circumstances under
which there are impediments to police
disclosing certain information to local
businesses but there were multiple
eyebrow raising examples of inaction
like from the Ottawa counselor who had
protesters show up at his home and
decided to move himself and his family
away for safety he reported the
situation to Ops but he never heard back
from them former police chief Peter
slowly's lawyer pushed back on a claim
the chief said he was scared early on in
a convoy phone call I remember being
scared personally
because I'm the chief saying at one
point you guys are scared I get it I'm
scared too he's going to say he didn't
say that right that instead he was
expressing why he understood people were
frightened day one of testimony in a
long six-week stretch and remember the
goal is to examine the federal
government's decision to invoke the
emergencies act starting off next week
more representatives from the city of
Ottawa including the mayor Abigail
Beeman Global News
Ottawa